Buenas tardes, todos. Bienvenidos a la clasa master de TradeStation.
Mi nombre es Jesús Nava, Soy el Director de la Client Trending e Educación para los securidades de TradeStation.
Para mí siempre es un placer unirme a todos y hablar un poco sobre TradeStation.
Hoy vamos a hacer una serie de TradeSt rotations en las que destacamos
ciertas características de desarrollo estratégico de la plataforma TradeStation.
Hoy vamos a hablar sobre la magia de Portfolio y vamos a entrar en eso en un momento
y las razones por las que queréis usarlo.
Antes de comenzar, aquí están las discusiones usuales.
Recuerden que cada símbolo y idea
que hablamos en esta presentación
es para propósitos educativos.
Estas no son recomendaciones de TradeStation.
Además, que el trading activo no es apto para todos
y que la performance histórica no garantiza resultados futuros.
Para más información sobre estas discusiones,
visiten www.tradestation.com
o en forward slash important dash information.
También tenemos algunas discusiones adicionales
en el fondo de la pantalla.
Y Manolo también ha compartido un enlace en el chat
para quien quiera un poco más de detalle.
Bien, vamos a ir a la plataforma de TradeStation
y hablar de este tool interesante
que está disponible como aplicación
dentro de la plataforma de TradeStation.
Antes de ir a Portfolio Maestro
y por qué queréis usarlo,
vamos a establecer nuestra análisis de cartas
con una estrategia, solo una idea,
para que podamos empezar usando esa idea
y transferir esa estrategia a Portfolio Maestro.
Así que creo que si has estado en una de mis clases de maestro,
ya sabes que encuentro la estrategia de desarrollo
y estrategia de trade un tema fascinante
y estoy seguro de que ustedes van a disfrutar de esto también.
Voy a ir aquí a estudios y agregar una de las estrategias
construidas que son parte de la plataforma de TradeStation.
Estudios y estrategias.
Voy a empezar con MACD.
Creo que es una estrategia que he usado
en muchos de mis ejemplos anteriores.
Voy a
entrar en el mercado cuando el MACD genera una entrada larga,
pero voy a combinar eso con un truco ATR.
A pesar de lo volatil que ha sido el mercado
o de lo grande que están obteniendo las barras,
cada símbolo tendrá un truco adaptable
a base de su volatilidad.
A veces usamos el ATR como medida de movimiento de precio,
así que hace sentido introducir
algunas de esas calculaciones en nuestra estrategia
porque entonces estamos haciendo la estrategia
que sea más sensible a lo que el mercado está haciendo
en un momento particular.
Y en este ejemplo particular,
hace más sentido porque quiero que la estrategia
también sea aplicada a múltiples símbolos.
Entonces, en vez de especificar un truco ATR
de una cantidad específica,
digamos que yo lo sete a $500 como ejemplo,
en vez de tener esa cantidad específica,
que podría traducir de manera diferente
dependiendo del símbolo que estás usando.
Si estás usando un truco de valor alto como Tesla,
que es el símbolo que tenemos aquí en el fondo,
cada parada es de $246.
Así que un truco ATR de $500,
o sea, considerando el valor de la parada,
eso es diferente de aplicar un truco ATR de $500
en una parada como Verizon,
que está empezando, creo, en el rango de $30.
Así que la razón...
Usando el truco ATR,
tenemos una forma de estandardizar el truco de Airster-Helling
basado en cómo la seguridad se mueve.
Así que déjame ir adelante y dejar que se resuelva
la entrada de MACD.
Voy a escoger hacia el very top.
Déjame encontrar los trucos ATR, aquí están.
Bien, y voy a agarrar el botón de control
y clicar en el truco ATR LX,
LX para la entrada larga.
Así que, al agarrar el botón de control,
puedes seleccionar múltiples estrategias,
lo que hice aquí,
seleccioné la entrada larga de MACD con el truco ATR LX.
Voy a poner esas estrategias en el truco.
La estrategia encontrará cada área o cada instancia
donde la estrategia generaría una entrada y una salida.
Puedes ver que en un mercado de tendencia,
estas entradas de MACD parecen muy bonitas.
Y el hecho de que el mercado esté uptrendido
significa que el truco no va a ser atrapado
hasta que se encuentre con ese movimiento hacia abajo.
En este caso, lo encontré aquí.
Así que esta es una estrategia de forma de caja.
Voy a ir aquí a la tabla de datos
y clicar en el reporte de la estrategia.
Vamos a la sumergencia de la performance.
Vamos a abrir esto un poco.
Podemos ver los resultados de la estrategia.
Esta es una estrategia que va de 5 años.
¿Cómo se sabe eso?
Bueno, sé la cantidad de datos defaultes
que tengo en mi análisis de gráficos,
pero también veo aquí en el topo,
en la tabla de los reportes de la estrategia de performance
y puedes ver que dice,
septiembre 26 de 2018 a septiembre 26 de 2023.
Así que un total de 5 años.
No tuvimos mucha actividad de intercambio en esos 5 años.
Puedes ver que el total número de intercambios es solo de 35.
Así que tal vez los intercambios sean de pequeño tamaño
para que yo haga algunas asumciones
sobre la estrategia en sí misma.
Quiero que mi estrategia reporte
tener una cantidad significativa de intercambios
para que te dé un poco más de confianza
sobre lo que la estrategia está haciendo.
Pero puedes ver cómo esta estrategia particular
es profitable para Tesla.
¿Fue profitable para Tesla?
Deja que lo aclaremos.
Y lo dijimos al principio.
El hecho de que estamos buscando
una estrategia de reporte de performance
y vemos que la estrategia ha realizado de una manera cierta,
no significa que va a hacer esa misma
o experiencia, ese mismo comportamiento,
avanzando y eso es algo que nosotros,
como estrategias, debemos de ser conscientes de.
Así que es muy imposible
esperar que las estrategias sean las mismas.
Sin embargo, en un contexto histórico,
esta estrategia generó algunos ganancias.
$16,000 de ganancias netas en un periodo de cinco años,
no es malo.
Si cambié el símbolo, aquí en la parte de atrás,
la estrategia recalculará.
Así que digamos que me switché el símbolo a Microsoft.
Recalcula la estrategia.
Noten que, de nuevo, el total número de intercambios
es de 33 intercambios.
Esta es una estrategia que, por Microsoft,
generó unos $9,000 de ganancias netas.
El factor de ganancias es de 1.54.
Usualmente veo el factor de ganancias
más que hago el total de ganancias netas,
incluso si quieres una estrategia
que sea profitable para empezar.
Pero al mismo tiempo, quieres saber
cuál es el ratio de ganancias con los ganancias.
No es todo sobre el total de ganancias netas
porque a veces, si el factor de ganancias es demasiado bajo,
es muy imposible para la estrategia
mantener esa ganancia.
El factor de ganancias de 1.5 significa
que por cada dólar que has perdido,
has ganado $1.50.
Así que tenemos ese tipo, ese ratio
cuando comparas ganancias con ganancias.
Así que el mayor el ratio significa
que el ratio de ganancias con los ganancias
es favorables a tu rendimiento, ¿cierto?
Vamos a ver algunas áreas de la reporta de la estrategia
de ganancias.
Porque quería mencionar que cuando haces
un test de vuelta de estrategia, como lo hice,
esto funciona muy bien para solo un símbolo.
Notas que empecé con Tesla,
miré la reporta de ganancias de estrategia,
luego mudé el símbolo a Microsoft
y parece que es favorable para eso también.
Si lo mudé a Apple,
podemos ver que es favorable.
Veamos el factor de ganancias de Apple, 3.75.
Y, por supuesto, es kind of expected
en un mercado uptrendido
para tener estos grandes intercambios.
La entrada de MACD entra en el mercado
y no sale hasta que tengamos un precio bajista
que sea suficiente significativo
para que se encuentre con la entrada de ganancias ATR.
Por default, esta entrada de ganancias utiliza tres ATR.
Entonces, lo que sea el valor de la entrada de ganancias ATR,
se multiplica por tres
y se establece como la entrada de ganancias.
Entonces, notas que aunque en este uptrendido
tuvimos algunas áreas en las que el precio se corregió
por unos días, no se corregió suficiente
para que nosotros lleguemos a esa entrada de ganancias.
No fue hasta aquí que el precio
realmente se corregió
y que nuestra entrada de ganancias se acercó aquí.
Y fue un buen tiempo
porque puedes ver que después de eso
el mercado continuó a bajar.
Así que muchas veces vas a encontrar intercambios como este.
Se ven muy bien.
Pero, de nuevo, esto es un backtest histórico.
Quiero decir, nadie puede sentarse allí
mirando los datos históricos
y pinpointar dónde sería la entrada óptima y la salida, ¿verdad?
Entonces, vamos a volver aquí
a mi reporte de performance.
Hice un símbolo.
Creo que fue Disney.
Sí.
Por ejemplo, si cambias a Disney,
puedes ver que no es un buen reporte aquí.
Tenemos una estrategia de perdida aquí.
El factor de ganancias es de 89 centavos.
Así que siempre vas a estar en el negativo.
En este caso particular,
por cada dólar que perdimos,
solo hicimos 89 centavos.
Así que no es un buen ratio.
Aunque si sigues a cambiar el símbolo,
puedes encontrar que muchos símbolos
tienen una performance profitable.
Idealmente, cuando estás desarrollando una estrategia,
quieres un método que te permita hacer
el backtest de un portfólio.
Así que tienes una estrategia en mente.
En este caso, muy simple.
Las reglas que seleccionamos aquí son muy simples.
Magdi, entrada óptima,
y luego tenemos un atr traicionamiento.
Pero lo que quieres hacer es que quieras aplicar
esa misma estrategia a un portfólio de símbolos
para que puedas agarrar la robustidad
de la estrategia en diferentes mercados.
¿Qué es el punto de encontrar una buena estrategia
si solo funciona en un símbolo particular?
En fin, esa estrategia va a fallar.
Tenemos una estrategia profitable en Tesla,
cambiamos el símbolo a Disney,
y entonces es una estrategia de perdida.
Así que no lo consideraría como una estrategia robusta.
Así que si puedes aplicar esa estrategia
a un portfólio de símbolos
y luego obtener un reporte basado en ese portfólio,
entonces puedes agarrar tu estrategia y decir,
bueno, parece que es profitable en general.
Así que si traigo 20 o 30 símbolos
y los traigo con esta estrategia,
parece que, basado en los números históricos,
voy a quedarse afloat en el lado positivo.
Pero eso es solo posible si tienes un instrumento
que te permite retestar una estrategia
contra un portfólio de símbolos.
Y eso es donde el portfólio maestro viene a placer.
Es divertido, estoy solo riendo
porque tenía un colegio que ríe
con la forma en la que pronuncio maestro
porque tiene esa pronunciación española,
es una palabra española.
Así que, o maestro o maestro,
lo que quieras pronunciarlo,
ese es el método que vamos a hablar hoy.
Así que vamos a cerrar el reporte de estrategia y performance.
Voy a venir aquí a mis aplicaciones
y la aplicación que estoy hablando de
está aquí, el portfólio maestro.
Vamos a abrirlo.
Todo el mundo debería tenerlo como parte de las aplicaciones
que son parte de TradeStation.
Así que déjame ir adelante y maximizar esto.
Bien, vas a encontrar
que hay muchos botones y herramientas aquí.
Voy a caminar a través de un backtest de portfólio
y voy a mostrarles cómo comenzar.
No tengo ningún documento de download,
así que no estamos usando nada customizado.
Esto es todo lo que está construido en TradeStation.
Y puedes jugar con la funcionalidad
y usarlo tú mismo,
lo que es lo que quiero encargar a todos a hacer.
Justo después de la clase,
set up different portfolios
y test them and see all the different functionality
that we have there.
By the way, another thing that I wanted to mention,
and I'll do this right now.
Let me bring this page over here.
All right, this is...
Let me just...
Oh, hold on.
This is...
Let me just remove this bar at the top.
This is our events page.
I know that Manolo usually shares the link here in the chat.
Manolo, if you can do that right now.
But if you go to the learn section of TradeStation,
the events section,
you're gonna find that on October 10th,
we have a follow-up to this class.
This class, which is available for you to register,
is titled rank, filter,
and manage your positions
when backtesting on Portfolio Maestro.
It's a follow-up class
because I go into more advanced features
of Portfolio Maestro.
So today is more like an introductory class.
I'm gonna show you how to get it started,
how to create the strategy groups,
how to create the portfolio.
And then October 10th,
I'll go over the ranking, the filtering,
and how to manage your positions
when running the backtesting on Portfolio.
So make sure that if you like this class
and you're interested,
you register for the October 10th class,
which is just part two of this presentation, okay?
Perfect.
So here's Portfolio Maestro.
I'm not gonna look at anything that is a sample portfolio
or a sample strategy group.
I'm gonna go right into thinking about the idea
that we started off with during this presentation,
which is the MACD long-end tree
combined with an ATR trailing stop.
And I wanna see how that strategy works
on a portfolio of samples.
So the first thing that you need to do,
you have two buttons here on the left-hand side.
You have one that says manage portfolio
and manage strategy groups.
The first thing you need to do
is create the strategy group,
and then we're gonna create the portfolio,
which is pretty much adding everything together,
like the symbols and the strategy all in a portfolio.
But let's start with the strategy group.
I'm gonna come over here to this section
for strategy groups.
You can see at the bottom
that we have sample strategy group one
and sample strategy group two.
As I said just a moment ago, we're just gonna ignore those.
And once I click on that button, manage strategy groups,
I'm just gonna click on new
right here on the top left corner.
This allows me to create a new strategy group.
I'm gonna call this strategy group MACD
and ATR trail, all right?
This example, I'm gonna work it on equities,
but notice that you can switch the asset class to futures
if you wanna do that.
I'm just gonna click okay.
And you can see that at the bottom,
it created that strategy group, MACD and ATR trail.
So the next step here is to add the strategy.
You can see that that's a button
we get right here at the very top.
So I'm gonna click here,
and this is gonna load all the strategies
that are built in to the TradeStation platform.
Not only the ones that are built in,
but also any custom strategy that you may have.
So if you have ownership of the strategy,
if you developed your own personal strategy
and wrote it in easy language,
I would be very interested in knowing
how that strategy works on a portfolio of symbols.
I'm sure that you bring it over here
and test it against a group of symbols.
So again, the same way that I did on the platform,
I'm gonna come here in portfolio maestro,
I'm going to find the MACD, long entry,
I'm going to highlight it,
but then I'm just gonna scroll up
and find the ATR trail LX.
Let me hold down the control key,
make sure that I have ATR trail LX highlighted,
and I have, did I highlight the MACD?
Okay, it's checked.
So it doesn't work as on the TradeStation platform,
we don't have check boxes.
So the MACD LE is checked,
and we just check the ATR trail and we just click okay.
So you can see that it adds the two strategies right here
on this top panel,
and I'm able to expand the details
of each one of these strategies.
I can open up the ATR trail LX,
and I can open up the MACD LE.
If you wanted to modify these inputs,
you would have to do it, let's see,
and I modified here.
That's one of the things that I wanted to,
you go in into strategy group.
Okay, there we go.
So for this example,
I'm gonna use the parameters that are here.
So the ATR is looking at 10 periods.
The ATR factor is three.
So it's using three ATRs for the trailing stop amount.
For the MACD,
we have the usual MACD values at 12, 26, and nine.
But if you wanted to adjust any of these parameters,
maybe you want to adjust the factor for the ATRs
or the number of bars that are used in the ATR calculator,
whatever it is,
you have to go into strategy group settings.
We'll go into some of these settings in just a moment,
but you go to the strategy inputs right here,
and this allows you to change those inputs
for any of the strategies
that you select right here on the top, okay?
Again, I'm just gonna use default parameters.
Merlin's asking,
how do you get the TS portfolio maestro
from the trade station?
You should have it available, Merlin.
If you go to the,
let me go back here to my trade station,
and let me know if anybody doesn't see it either,
but if you go to the apps,
you have portfolio maestro added here.
If you don't,
I believe there's a way for you to add it directly
on the client center,
on the trade station client center.
But if you don't have it,
I mean, you still go here and check,
and if you don't have it,
call client services and ask them
if they can enable it for you.
Okay, so Merlin found it.
Eduardo says he doesn't have it.
Don't you have to pay extra for portfolio maestro?
Jeff, depending on the pricing plan that you're on,
I think there are some tools that you pay extra for.
I'm not sure if anybody that has it here,
if you're paying for it,
if it's included in your plan,
but those are questions
that our client services department can answer
and let you know
if it's gonna cost you something or not.
But if you don't find portfolio maestro
right here in the apps section,
client services can add that for you,
or you can go to the trade station client center
and find trade station additional services.
And I believe portfolio maestro should be listed there.
All right, so let's go ahead and check my settings here.
So we already talked about changing inputs,
which I'm not gonna do.
I'm gonna just use it the way that it is.
Right here, the buttons allow me to add more strategies,
remove any of the strategies that I've added.
We're going into the settings of the strategy.
Let's go and take a look at some other settings,
because here in general,
you can specify commissions
if you're paying any commissions on stocks.
You can also do some back testing resolution
if you want to.
This is not a class where we talk about resolution.
I have a whole class talking about
look inside bar back testing and back testing resolution,
which goes into details on why you would want to use it.
But for now, we're just gonna leave it the way it is.
We're not gonna turn that feature on.
And position limits,
this allows you to enter multiple times
in the same direction as the currently held position.
So in simple words,
if the MACD generates an entry,
it's gonna buy and take you long on that security.
But if it meets the criteria again a few days later,
it's gonna buy again and increase your position size.
So that's what position limits allows you to do.
It's a pyramiding strategy
where your position size continuously increases
as the market conditions are in your favor,
or at least going in the direction of the strategy.
So every time that the strategy generates a signal
is going to increase your position size.
If you don't turn this on,
the strategy will only take one trade
in one direction at a time.
So if it enters long based on the MACD,
it will not do anything else
until it exits that long position.
It will not enter until it exits.
So that's what position limits does.
But notice that the same strategy settings
that you find on the platform
when you back test strategies are found here.
I'm not sure how familiar you are with strategy,
back testing, but a lot of that functionality
that you find when you're testing a strategy
on an individual stock
are also available here in Portfolio Maestro,
which makes the tool very robust
because then you can account for other factors
like commissions, slippage,
anything that may affect the strategy performance.
In the quantity box, of course,
you can change the fixed amount.
I'm just gonna leave it.
This is a fixed amount.
What I'm gonna do is since I'm gonna...
The idea here is that I'm going to apply the strategy
to a basket of symbols
and every symbol will have a different price, of course.
So if I trade 100 shares,
the risk on any single position
is going to be different when compared to another
because of the price of the shares.
So if I set my amount per trade
on a fixed dollar amount and I say,
let me trade $10,000 per position.
So if you're trading, for example,
a stock like Tesla that is trading at $250,
that would only give you how many shares?
That would only give you about 10, like 40 shares?
Is my math correct?
So we can do amounts per trade.
So invest $10,000 per position.
I'm gonna round down to the nearest,
let's go here, 10 shares and minimum number
to make sure that you adjust those
because if you're trading Tesla, for example,
and you're only investing $10,000,
if you've minimum, if it's 100 shares,
it won't put on that trade
because 100 shares of Tesla is going to cost you $25,000
and you're saying only invest 10,000.
So if you wanna trade $10,000 worth of Tesla,
make sure that your minimum trade size here reflects that
so that it's able to place that trade.
All right, I wanna click okay.
By the way, on the back testing,
we have some other check boxes here
that are brought over from the strategy engine
on the trade station platform.
I also do a class on the back testing settings,
not the place here for that explanation,
but if you have to configure the strategy,
then please take a look
at my other strategy trading presentations.
And that's it, I'm gonna click okay.
All right, so that's, I have the strategy.
I have the trade size already set up.
So now I'm gonna go here to the symbol list tab
because now I have to select the symbols
that I want to apply this strategy on.
So I'm gonna click on plus, add symbol.
Notice that we get access to the trade station
prepackaged list of symbols and any symbol list
that you've created yourself.
So if I go here to trade station symbol lists,
this is where, I'm sorry,
not the trade station symbol lists,
the trade station custom symbol list.
This is where the custom symbol lists
that you create would be listed.
I have a few here that I've created myself,
depending on the presentation that I have,
but you can go to the other categories here
if you want to scan.
I mean, if you wanna apply the strategy
on a particular sector,
or if you wanna do an index component,
notice that let's do the NASDAQ.
Let's not choose something as big as the 100
because that would mean that there's a potential
for you to have a position on each one of these 100 symbols.
If we specify the trade size to be $10,000 worth
and you multiply 10,000 by 100 symbols,
we are talking about how much?
We're talking about a million dollars
that you need in your account
in order to maintain a $10,000 position
in each one of these symbols.
Does that make sense?
So always think in terms of what is my account
capable of trading?
Look at your funds and make sure
that you're setting up your back test
in a way that you would be able to trade it.
So let me not choose the 100.
Let me go into the Dow Jones instead
and select the Dow Jones Industrial.
Let's see how it works in those 30.
It says 31 symbols in parentheses
because it also includes the symbol for the index itself,
dollar sign INDU.
Dollar sign INDU cannot be traded.
So I'm gonna look for a way to remove
that symbol from my test.
So John is asking how can you limit
the total amount traded to 100K?
That's a good question, John.
And when you're using strategies on trade station,
it's interesting because the strategy will assume
that you have enough money in your account to trade.
Now, when you do a portfolio back test,
there are some settings that you can tweak
in order to stop the strategy from trading
after a certain, whatever, number of positions
or after a capital has been invested.
So there are some ways that you can limit the portfolio.
However, on the initial stages of back testing,
there's no maximum amount that you can trade.
The strategy will assume that you can trade everything.
So if you say, like for example, I just did,
I told the strategy, I want you to trade $10,000
worth of every symbol.
And it'll assume that I have enough money in my account
to trade $10,000 worth of each symbol.
So if I supply 100 symbols, of course,
I'll need a million dollars in my account.
So those are the types of things
that you have to think about
when you're setting up the strategy
so that it's realistic to what your account is
and the funds that you have.
Of course, as I said just a moment ago,
there are some other constraints
and some other settings that you can turn on,
which is the topic that I'm going to cover
in the class of October 10th.
So here I'm going to select the 31 symbols,
even though there's one here that cannot be traded.
And let's see if I click OK here,
it adds the symbol list right here at the very top.
I'm able to expand it.
It gives me a description of each one of the symbols
that are added here to this group.
You can see the corporations.
I believe that I can, let's see,
if I select this one,
so this just gives me the properties for the symbol,
not what I wanted to do.
What I want to do, let's see, remove symbol,
confirm the list.
Are you sure you want to remove the selected symbol list?
I don't want to remove the symbol list.
I just want to remove a symbol.
Maybe it's not done here.
Interval settings.
All right, this is something else.
We'll look at the settings
and see how we can manage the symbol list.
I think I can do it later,
but the initial report is going to assume
that I'm able to trade the Dow Jones index when I can't.
Okay, let's go and take a look at the settings here.
You probably saw that I have interval settings.
So this is a, I'm going to do a daily back test.
So all the symbols are going to be loading daily bars
and the strategy is going to look at those daily bars.
I'm just going to click okay.
And at this point, these are all equities.
I'm not going to use additional data series.
Money management and ranking
are the features that I talked to you about.
I'm going to go into detail on those features
on the October 10th presentation.
But I just created what's called a strategy group,
which is a combination of strategies with symbols.
Now I'm going to build a portfolio
and I'm going to have additional settings that I can tweak.
So let's go over here to my manage portfolio button.
Notice that we're switching the button here.
And in here, I'm going to add, not add,
because what you see here,
this is a portfolio called sample portfolio two.
So it automatically loads a portfolio from the bottom
and I don't want to modify it.
So I'm just going to click over here at the very top
where it says new.
Again, we did it once when we created the strategy group.
Now we're doing it a second time
to create what's called the portfolio.
And this portfolio is going to be the MACD ATR trail.
And I'm just going to say DAO 30.
So I know that it's a back test.
The portfolio is a back test on the DAO 30.
I'm going to click OK.
Notice that it blanks out the top panel
because at this point it just creates
like a shell of the portfolio.
I need to bring in the strategy group
that I created just a moment ago.
So I'm going to click on this plus button
to add strategy group.
And you can see the list of strategy groups.
The one that I created was named MACD and ATR trail.
I'm going to click OK.
And here we see the two strategies
that we have in the strategy group
and we have the symbol here.
So we can expand and see all the symbols.
We can expand the strategies as well
and see the parameters of each one of those strategies.
You can remove the strategy group.
And at this point you have two buttons.
You have portfolio settings.
And over here on the right you have back test portfolio.
Let's go into portfolio settings
to see some of the things we can do.
Constraints and portfolio stops
are also two of the things we're going to talk about
on October 10th.
These are settings that you can apply to a portfolio level
and not on an individual strategy.
Now the MACD, LE and the ATR trail
that we selected earlier
is going to run on individual symbols.
But these other settings, constraints and portfolio stops
are set at the portfolio level,
not looking at individual symbols.
But here in the general tab, this is all fine.
I'm going to click OK.
All right, I'm going to go into...
I have a delete button here.
No?
So let's go into the back test portfolio dialog.
I'm just clicking on this back test portfolio.
I see information about what this is going to do.
So let me give this report a name.
MACD ATR trail on the Dow 30.
The initial capital that you see here,
you may think that it's what John was asking about.
John was asking, how do I limit my strategy or my portfolio
so that it doesn't trade more than $100,000?
You may think that this is that, but it's not.
The initial capital that you see right here,
it's only to calculate
what is called the return on initial capital.
So if my strategy is able to make $10,000
on a $100,000 capital,
it's just going to be a 10% return on initial capital.
So it's only used in the calculation
of return on initial capital.
So if you want to make this 100,000,
what you really have in your account, you can,
so that you can get those return on initial capital
calculations to be a little bit more accurate.
But remember that if you see return on initial capital
on the strategy performance report or any reporting
is based on this starting point, $100,000.
This is going two years back.
On the symbols that we looked at
on the TradeStation platform, we were going back five years.
So it's okay for us to go back five years.
Always be mindful of the number of symbols
you have in your portfolio.
I only have 30 symbols or 31 to be exact.
I'm going to try to remove that index symbol,
but I have 30 symbols.
It's not such a big deal to load five years
of historical data on each one of these symbols.
I'm only loading daily bars.
If I were loading five years of one minute,
maybe it's a different story.
But I'm not saying that you couldn't because you can.
I mean, we have intraday data here in Portfolio Maestro
and you can do intraday back testing.
But for the example we're working on, this is okay.
Five years of daily data on 30 symbols
is not going to be very taxing on the report here.
You also have access to other advanced settings
that you find on the TradeStation platform.
One of my prior strategy trading classes
that we did together was on optimization.
And we talked about the different methods
of optimization and so forth.
But that's, of course, a different class, you know?
And it's interesting that I always refer
to different classes just that it's impossible
to be able to fit everything in just one session.
And I'm just referring to these other classes
because I want you to be aware that we've done presentations
on a lot of these features and there's a lot
of educational content that you can reference
if you need some additional help, okay?
So we have the name here.
We have five years of historical data, okay?
This is all good.
I'm gonna leave my backtest type to standard strategy inputs.
I'm not changing anything here.
I'm just leaving everything the way it is.
And the symbols.
Oh, this is where I can exclude the dollar sign INDU
which I'm just gonna check the box here for exclude.
And there is another column here that says create.
Create is, I think it's create chart is what it says.
Yeah, create chart.
What it allows you to do, and this is interesting,
and we'll do it later, but I think it allows you
to see where the entries and exits are on a chart
because I mean, Portfolio Maestro doesn't have charting
like the Trade Station platform does.
And if you wanted to see a chart of the historical backtest,
then you have to make sure that these check boxes are checked.
Let's go ahead and do it.
I mean, it doesn't matter.
I'm just gonna click on this button that says
create all charts, okay?
So everything is checked.
I still have that check box on excluding
the dollar sign INDU, and I'm ready.
So all I need to do is click on perform backtest.
I just click it, and you can see that this initializes
and it's downloading historical data,
and you're gonna see that it doesn't take very long
for us to get the results.
Okay, the analysis is completed.
I'm gonna click on the button that says view report now.
One thing that I want you guys to notice is that
over here on the left-hand side,
I was moved from the portfolio section.
I was moved to the reporting section.
There's a reports tab here.
And we have, of course, the performance report.
We have an optimization report.
Interesting, my camera just died on me.
Okay, so we have optimization report
if you were running an optimization
within Portfolio Maestro, which you can.
And then we have some other reports here.
But what I wanna show you is these numbers.
This is an overall performance
on the 30 symbols combined.
Let's point out a few items here.
The total return is 86,506.
This is a total return when trading all 30 symbols.
You can see that gross profit,
it almost reached $300,000.
The loss was about $200,000.
So the profit factor right here is 1.42.
Okay, so for every dollar we made $1.42,
which a little low in my opinion,
but it's interesting that we're still
on a positive side of the strategy.
Notice the number of trades.
In a period of five years,
if you were trading all 30 symbols,
you would have traded 1,007 times
in that five-year time span.
We have a 43% profitability,
making 439 winning trades, 568 losing trades.
And remember, this is all numbers
on the overall performance of the portfolio.
Now, if you wanted to see the individual performance
and break down this total return per symbol,
you can go into the Trade Analysis tab.
Trade Analysis tab gives you similar numbers,
but here you have the ability to view hide.
Right here at the bottom right corner,
there's a view hide button.
I'm gonna click it.
And it just gives you a list of all the symbols
that make up this report.
I can click on this top checkbox next to symbol,
so that all the checkbox are highlighted,
and then I just click okay.
And this, of course, gives me a column
for each one of the symbols
that are part of the historical backtest.
And I believe these are,
I'm sure these are sorted in the way that they were traded.
That's why you have Johnson & Johnson
right here at the very beginning.
I don't think there's any,
I don't think it's sorted in any way
other than what was the first symbol that was traded.
Now, let's go here to the trade list
to confirm that theory.
I'm gonna go to the trade list and go over here.
This is back in 2018.
The first trade was done December 12th.
So 2018.
And you can see the symbol right here
is Johnson & Johnson.
So the order in which the columns are aligned
is the order in which the trades were generated.
And even though we go back five years,
so the chart should have loaded from September,
not December, the first trade is in December.
I'm not sure if you guys have done enough historical backtest
to have an understanding of why it started in December.
But maybe you know,
maybe you've heard of this term max bars back setting.
The strategy reserves an amount of data
at the beginning of the historical backtest for calculation.
And by default, that number's 50 bars.
And that's the reason why
we don't have earlier trades than December,
because that's when the strategy was able to generate trades.
But you can see the sequence of trades,
and you can see that it started with Johnson & Johnson,
and how many shares did it trade?
The price was 147 at that time,
right here, the quantity, 60 shares.
It was able to trade 60 shares.
Remember that in the trade size dialogue that we adjusted,
we specified that we wanted a $10,000 investment
on each one of these stocks,
and we wanted to round it down to 10 shares.
So you're not gonna see trades here that are lower than 10,
because we set that as a minimum.
And you don't see any odd number of shares.
So it's always rounded down to the nearest 10, 10 shares.
So you're not gonna see 61 or 62,
it's gonna round it down to 60.
So that's our first trade,
60 shares of Johnson & Johnson, not a profitable trade.
You can see that it lost $381 right here,
but you can see the history of all the trades
that were generated.
Pretty cool, huh?
Let's go here, and you have a lot of other tabs
that you can analyze in terms of performance.
You have returns on equity, equity table,
you have all the symbols visible here,
periodical returns,
the graphs, this is our equity curve line,
that's interesting,
and the settings for the strategy.
So the same performance metrics that you find
in the TradeStation platform
when you're developing a strategy
and you're looking at the strategy,
performance report,
you're gonna find all those same metrics
right here in Portfolio Maestro.
Another thing that I wanted to show you,
remember that checkbox that we checked
for us to be able to see a chart?
Let me go here to,
let me just see where I find that.
Okay, here we go.
At the very top,
you see where it says view trade charts?
I'm gonna click there,
and let me just see.
This gives me a window
with the strategy that I tested,
and here you can select the chart you want to see.
So if I wanna see a chart of Apple,
I just click on this little button for view chart,
and it opens up a chart for Apple.
Let me go ahead and exit out of this.
Oh, it actually closes it.
So let me go back in there.
View trade charts.
Let's go and open this up.
I'm gonna select Apple.
Let's view the chart.
How do I, let me move it out of the way.
All right, and in here in the chart,
I'm able to see the entries and exits of Apple.
This kinda, and it's not like trade station charting.
Let's get that straight.
But here, I'm able to see
what the strategy entered and exited.
You have the zoom out and the zoom in buttons here
if you wanted to get a little bit more detail, you know?
And of course, the time scale right here at the bottom.
Let me go ahead and exit out of this chart.
You want to, no, let's close this.
Okay, there we go, and close it.
So that's where you get the charting
if you wanted to see a chart.
I would rather go to the trade station platform
because I'm more familiar with the functionality there,
but this is the report.
So hopefully you got the steps.
You know, I just wanted to give you the introduction
on how to get Portfolio Maestro started.
First, you have to create the strategy group
with the symbols.
Then you have to create the portfolio.
You go into the settings of the portfolio
and you start the back test.
And then it just sends you here into the summary.
You can see that some symbols, of course,
have a negative return like Verizon
provided or generated a negative return.
Same for MMM, MMM.
You know, most of the symbols are positive,
which is interesting, you know?
Another thing that I wanted to show you is that
when you come over here to the trade log,
because one of the things that
Portfolio Maestro doesn't do is
it doesn't allow you to automate this.
Yes, it would be great for us to have the ability
to turn on a switch and say,
okay, do your thing, run the strategy on 30 symbols,
trade it based on my limitations,
whether the limitations are trade size,
constraints, portfolio stops,
whatever it is that I want to set,
turn it on and let the Portfolio Maestro tool
automate my strategy, but it doesn't do that.
But what it does do is give you a trace,
not the trace log, orders report right here, orders report.
So it does tell you what you need to do on a daily basis.
For example, here it tells you that you needed to,
UNH is United Healthcare, right?
So you needed to sell the 20 shares at $482.
This is the ATR LX was met yesterday.
You can see the action date is yesterday.
It doesn't use today's data because today hasn't closed yet.
And the historical back test here is loading,
of course, closed bars.
So you can see all the signals that were generated
as of yesterday.
Well, yesterday was Monday at 4 p.m.
And you have all your selling transactions.
These are all selling transactions.
We don't have any new trades going in.
These are open orders.
Positions, okay, you have your open orders.
It gives you the specific price that you need to sell at
based on the trailing stock.
This is what it is.
These are your trailing stock values
based on the calculated ATR.
These are your open positions.
You can see that United Healthcare is right there.
You entered, this is the opening price.
You entered at $445.
And you need a selling transaction at $482 or lower.
What's the price?
We need to find out what the price of United Healthcare
is at the moment.
Oh, $488.
That's where the price is, $488.
So you can see that you're setting your trailing stock
already for this position you currently have.
So based on the strategy,
these are the positions that you currently have
on your account.
And these are the filled orders for today
and the canceled orders.
It does give you details on what you need to do
to the strategy to be in sync with your report,
which is pretty cool.
Of course, you'd have to run it every single day
at the very end of the day
so you can get updated orders and updated positions.
Remember that the strategy,
the strategy is something that is calculated
on the close of every bar.
And if we're doing a strategy back test on daily bars,
then the strategy gets generated
at the close of every single day.
And that's the reason why it says 4 p.m.
And that's the reason why we're saying
you need to run it every single day
to get new orders, new reports.
It doesn't run automatically is what we're trying to say,
but it does give you which positions you should have open,
which orders you should be submitting.
And what orders to cancel and which orders to fill.
So pretty, pretty cool.
Let's see, how can you...
Okay, so from Malton, from Malton, yes.
Or Malone, I'm sorry.
I need to put my glasses on.
Is there a way to see individual total return
to check which performance?
Yes, exactly.
We do that here on the performance report.
Trade analysis is what we did here
as we displayed every single column.
We have this button here at the bottom right,
which allows you to hide or enable.
I'm just clicking on the checkbox here to add them,
and I see the individual return.
Jeff said, did you say that you cannot turn on
the strategy to run automatically?
Yes, I did say that, and I'm just reiterating that
you cannot turn this on for automation,
although it does give you a lot of details
as to what needs to be open,
what needs to be in active order,
and what needs to be done to your strategy.
Can you run the strategy automatically
in the TradeStation platform outside of Portfolio Maestro?
Of course you can.
In fact, I have 30 symbols in here,
so yes, I could theoretically have 30 charts open
on the platform, have the same strategy applied
to each one of the charts,
and have them turned on automatically.
The only problem of doing it that way
is that every chart will be independent,
so it will not be run as a portfolio.
Portfolio Maestro has this other layer of constraints
and stop level, I mean, portfolio level stops,
and some ranking and some filtering
that is done at the portfolio level.
So it does allow you to do some decision-making
as to what positions to put on.
If you go to the TradeStation platform
and you open up 30 individual charts
and automate 30 individual strategies,
then they're all going to be independent,
and there's not gonna be anything
cross-checking the symbols to see
which ones should be traded and which ones shouldn't.
So we're gonna get to more of that
in our next session, October 10th,
so make sure that you register for that session
if you'd like to learn a little bit more
about Portfolio Maestro.
But this is my class.
I hope that you guys enjoyed it.
If you have any questions, please feel free to reach out
to us at educationattradestation.com,
and we're there for you for any concerns,
and I want to wish everyone a wonderful afternoon.
I hope to see you in a future class.
Goodbye, everyone.
Great having you today.
Bye-bye.